[Music]
there is a pip squeak
there is a scumbag in norway
him and his group
who are burning the quran every single
week
with the permission not only that but
the protection of the norwegian
government in fact
our
proud sponsors and friends
islamnet have told us themselves that
they were being harassed by this group
do you see this banner stating oslo
jihad center we have alhamdulillah
purchased this huge property to
establish a masjid and community center
for the muslims in norway
and today subhanallah we found this
banner put up by a norwegian extremist
anti-muslim group known for burning the
quran and wanting to deport muslims from
the country
this individual lars
thorne
who is burning the quran thinking that
the muslim community is somehow
scared of him or something or that this
has an impact
the quran even tells us this i mean
quite frankly itself it says
that do not let those individuals who
are
who are running and chasing this belief
upset you oh muhammad
[Music]
they have a very painful punishment
now these individuals who are attacking
the religion of islam
are just one part of the bigger problem
the bigger problem that we saw some
years ago created this monster anders
breivik who killed 77 people in cold
blood who is now demanding more kind of
privileges in his cell
that the norwegian government only gave
a slap in the wrist
but i have a challenge for this
individual
that i will educate him not even a
challenge is
something for him i will educate him on
a zoom meeting i have a discussion with
him
maybe something like this maybe this is
a challenge that you would uh accept
because at the end of the day
who do you think you are to tr to try
and burn the quran in this manner
yeah you think you're a big man yeah
you're nothing brother yeah you're
nothing you and your organization you
try and uh harass our brothers at islam
net
well i'll tell you what islam that
and i know this because i'm in contact
with the brothers are now building a
masjid and tawa center tangible assets
that the ummah can see the money is
going in the right places and the more
you do what you do the more we'll do
what we do which is we'll raise money
more and more money to expand this
project and in fact for every quran that
you try and burn will raise a hundred
thousand euros yes hundred thousand
hundred thousand euros
and so my call to action to the muslim
community is this
we must make sure that islam is strong
and aziz is mighty in every part of the
world
and so this our project make sure in
this holy month this holy month these
holy days of ramadan that we do as much
as we can
make sure that you click on the link
below and you donate as much as you can
put as much as you can into the matter
because this might not this opportunity
might not come knocking again with
salaam alaikum
water
you